[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
an update on a cruise ship nightmare a
judge ruling whether a cruise liner is
at fault in the case of a toddler who
fell to her death
here robert durst's shocking jailhouse
call to his friend the real estate air
admitting he knew he was in trouble
from the tv series the jinx
and mark redwine's decision on whether
to take the stand the colorado father's
defense wraps up
as he stands trial in the murder of his
13 year old son plus
a former florida deputy is sentenced to
prison for planting drugs on innocent
people
she mr wester you've robbed me of my
credibility
being a mother and a grandmother law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a major ruling out of a florida district
court wednesday where royal caribbean
cruise line has been cleared of any
wrongdoing in the death
of an 18-month old girl
a judge throwing out a suit filed by the
parents of chloe wygand
a week before the civil case was set to
go to trial the cruise liner has argued
the girl's grandfather
salvatore nello was at fault for losing
his grip of the young girl
who fell several stories to her death
while the ship was docked in san juan
puerto rico in 2019
the company previous release
surveillance photos claiming they showed
anello
knew the window was open and he must
have known what he did
was dangerous anillo repeatedly insisted
he did not know the window was open
he was sentenced to three years of
probation earlier this year after
previously pleading guilty to negligent
homicide
the young girl's parents say they will
appeal wednesday's ruling claiming there
were not enough warning signs on the
ship
and to raise awareness of unintentional
toddler window falls
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney julie rendellman and terry
austin
julie the judge threw out the case
saying a reasonable person
would have known better what facts
brought the judge to their conclusion
so look this is an incredible tragedy
for the family and obviously for the
grandfather but the one thing that stood
out to the judge is that
when he said a reasonable person a
reasonable person in this defendant's
position
which is from at least the evidence
we've seen that he had lifted the child
up and clearly must have known that
there was a window there that was open
because he appeared to be holding the
child
over the window and so the judge said
you know a reasonable person in that
position
of course they're going to know that
it's open of course they're going to
know the risks
and to the benefit of the cruise ship
there didn't seem to be
any other cases at least not that i know
of in which such a danger or such event
occurred where someone was
injured and so the judge was saying you
know what they don't know
that there's no forewarning for the
cruise ship to think something like this
would ever have happened
and therefore the civil lawsuit fails
makes a lot of sense perhaps going
forward they will put up those signs to
dissuade people from doing this but at
least at this point
the judge found him not liable terry
this decision is a week before the
case was about to go to trial the family
has already said they plan to appeal
how do you seal that appeal going brian
i think they have a great chance
on appeal while there might not be many
cases the shipping industry and the
cruise line industry
in particular is highly highly regulated
there are safeties in place
the international marine time
organization has put regulations in
strict regulations saying
they should have crews that are trained
they should have equipment that is safe
and they should actually have guardrails
up so i think there's a good chance on
appeal
all right so maybe the rules and
regulations that hold these cruise lines
to
uh their feet to the fire so to speak
for regulations like this may find an
avenue there for appeal
thanks for the info turning now to other
top legal news
one of the nfl's most public figures is
in a kings county washington jail cell
where he's been denied bail till he sees
a judge
after being charged with burglary
domestic violence a felony
in the state free agent pro bowler
richard sherman
was arrested wednesday morning the case
is sealed but here's what we know
a superior court judge has ordered an
extreme risk protection order for the
former seahawk and 49er
the league's player association for
which sherman is vice president
says it will provide protection and
support for everyone involved
the nfl says it will also investigate
the incident
now to california where prosecutors are
playing damning jailhouse calls
made by robert durst after his arrest
for the murder of his best friend susan
berman
durst was taken into custody in march
2015 one day before the final episode of
the hbo series the jinx aired
the episode ended with durst in a
bathroom his microphone still hot
saying the now infamous lines killed
them all of course
in a recorded call from jail two months
later durst tells one of his friends
that he started to think he had a
problem after watching the fourth
episode
after watching the fifth dirt says he
knew he made a mistake
talking to the show's producers
[Music]
okay so what you went at what point
did you think you were in trouble
before i left
terry the most intriguing part of durs
realizing he's done
is that it gets worse after every
episode on the jinx
could this be it case closed based on
this testimony
i don't think it's case closed just yet
brian
i think that the jury has to try to
decipher
the meaning behind the words that he
said to
his friend janine clark i mean what he's
more concerned about here
is how he came across the impression
that he made
with the jinx he should be more
concerned about the truth
to me regretting what he said to the
producers of the jinx
regretting how he appeared on several
episodes
to me that means there is a
consciousness of guilt
it doesn't mean to me that he's innocent
at all well terry it's interesting
because we know that duress
through his lawyers have told us that
he's going to testify so maybe the why
is explained away in that testimony
can this evidence i don't know be
explained away by robert durst taking
the stand
you know i think that if he gets on the
stand he's got a lot of explaining to do
i think the jury is probably
looking for him to get on the stand and
durst has always wanted to talk
we've seen in the past that he's gotten
up and explained himself so i think he
would like to
explain everything that's happened with
all of the cases involved here not just
susan berman but of course maybe even
kathy durst and morris black so
i look forward to him getting on the
stand and explaining all of this away
it's gonna be interesting it's gonna be
a heavy lift for such a frail man but
he's going to try he's told to solve it
he's going to take the stand
and maybe explain all this away away
john lewin the prosecutor is going to be
excited for that opportunity
to cross robert durst thank you terry
still ahead on law and crime daily a man
who made a career
out of putting people behind bars finds
out how long he'll be in prison for
planting drugs
but first will a colorado father on
trial in the murder of his 13 year old
son
take the stand in his own defense mark
redwine's shocking decision
[Music]
next
welcome back the defense has rested its
case in the trial of mark redwine the
man accused of killing his 13 year old
son
in 2012. law encrimes angenet levy is
here
with how the defense ended its case and
what comes next well brian the defense
called witnesses with the goal of
casting doubt on the police
investigation
into the disappearance and death into of
dylan redwine and mark redwine most
importantly decided not to take the
stand
to tell the jury his story
i've decided not to testify your honor
okay and is this your decision
yes it is and with that mark redwine
remains silent about his son's
disappearance
instead his attorney questioned the
coroner about dylan redwine's death
certificate
on this pending
certificate of death what did you
determine as
manner undetermined
jan smith said dylan redwine's cause of
death was also listed as undetermined
but she later changed the manner of
death to homicide
a decision with which she had to grapple
i had to make sure
that what i had or what i knew
was the death occurred because of the
results of someone else's actions
smith said she saw part of dylan
redwine's skull at a hospital where she
met with an investigator and a forensic
anthropologist
the skull was x-rayed and smith said it
had marks on it
did you take into account the context in
this case
and changing it from undetermined to
homicide i did
a former employee of mark redwines told
the jury how he believed red wine felt
about dylan
he's like he was his pride and joy
freddie krasium described redwine
becoming emotional when discussing dylan
before he went missing
he didn't have tears his eyes advised
his emotion
and he showed me pictures of his son
playing baseball but the prosecutor
questioned cranium's objectivity since
mark redwine had given him a promotion
you've never even met dylan no but i've
seen plenty of pictures about them i
know about them right
it's a simple simple question you never
met the child
never got to but i wanted to you never
saw mark redwine and
dylan redwine interact no sir
you really other than what mark has told
you you really don't know anything about
their relationship isn't that right
well not just what he told me other than
what you saw and what he told you you
don't know anything you never saw them
in iraq
that's right i never seen it together
thank you no further questions
now after the defense rested its case
the prosecution put on
a short rebuttal case they called a
young woman
who lived in the area back in 2012. a
postal worker had actually
testified earlier in the trial that she
saw a child
who may have been dylan redwine walking
on a road
the day after he disappeared she
actually said there were two kids but
she wasn't sure it was dylan well this
young woman said that she and her friend
were actually
walking down the road that day they were
going to a store and that her friend had
a very similar haircut to dylan's
she said the two kids actually knew
dylan redwine but they did not see him
in the area that day
brian thanks angenet let's bring back
co-host terry austin to get to the
bottom
of this red wine story terry so what's
the difference between
undetermined and homicide and what
exactly is the defense trying to get out
here
well the difference is when you have a
determination that it's a homicide it
just simply
means that the victim has died at the
hands of another and undetermined means
exactly that that they can't
determine how the individual died so
here i think what the defense is trying
to do
is to cast some doubt on this
coroner or medical examiner as they're
called in some states
and say that your preliminary death
certificate
had one thing and the final amended
death certificate
had another so it's trying to raise some
doubt as far as the jury's concerned
that perhaps it really is in this
coroner's mind
an undetermined cause and manner of
death so i think that
it's just trying to raise some doubt
yeah the coroner has some doubt maybe
the jury should have some doubt as well
i mean that's what we're trying to get
at
terry now redwine doesn't have to
testify i get that but do you think that
this case
needed him to take the stand to explain
some of his behavior to the jury
well it's interesting because when the
judge was asking him are you going to
testify do you understand that you have
the right to testify
are you waiving those rights initially i
did think that red wine was going to get
on the stand
because he has a lot of explaining to do
but he talked to his lawyer and
as a matter of fact they took a little
break and they took some more
conversation
and then he testified at that trial that
he's not going to get on that stand to
testify in front of the jury so we're
not going to hear him i do think he owes
the jury an explanation and i think
they're going to
wonder what it is that he would have
said had he taken the stand
well they continue to wonder but the
judge will tell him they can't hold it
against him
and jeanette now that both sides have
rested what's next in the trial
well they're going to present both sides
will present their closing arguments on
thursday morning the judge said that
they will be ordering lunch in for the
jurors he told them that
after the state rested its rebuttal case
he said he didn't know how long that
lunch would be
but obviously they'll hear those closing
arguments and then deliberations will
begin
so whether or not they'll have a verdict
before the end of the week
we'll just have to wait and see right
lunch deliberation
maybe some closing arguments laid in
there we'll make sure to have you
covered here the law and crime network
for gavel to gavel coverage
of the colorado vs mark redwine trial
thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily the
latest twist in the investigation
into the murder of a college student
molly tibbetts plus
the teen charged with killing 17 people
inside a florida high school
is in court on a separate matter this
jailhouse brawl
welcome back nicholas cruz the teenager
charged with shooting and killing
17 students and staff at a florida high
school was back
in court wednesday for the first time in
over a year
lawyers argued over access to cruz's
medical records stemming from this fight
with a prison guard in november
of 2018 ending with crews on the ground
and a gun pointed at him before
being put in handcuffs his trial for the
2017 shooting
at marjory stoneman douglas high school
has been delayed for more than a year
due to the pandemic the court says it
may begin in september
cruz's lorries have suggested he would
plead guilty in exchange for a life
sentence
while prosecutors are continuing to seek
the death penalty
the sentencing for the man convicted of
killing an iowa college student is
delayed
after a prison inmate claims someone
else confessed to the murder
christian beginner rivera was supposed
to be sentenced for molly tibbett's
murder this week
but now that's on hold his lawyers are
asking for a new trial
citing the inmate coming forward with
information about the confession
bahina rivera's lawyers also claim
prosecutors
should have turned over information to
them about a man accused of sex
trafficking
and reports of children missing from the
area a hearing will be held on the
defense request
for the information on thursday
let's check in with our chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
with what he's been working on this week
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
a fascinating story about what airline
pilots and flight attendants call
the smelly socks problem that's how they
describe a smell they see in the cockpit
and the cabin
caused they say by engine oil bleeding
into the airflow
causing serious problems officials say
153 people
are on board american airlines flight
965.
the crew reportedly radioed in with
engine trouble
moments before it crashed northeast of
cali
this was a crew that was probably the
most experienced
crew you could have had but on that
night i believe
they were cognitively impaired not to
the point that they couldn't talk
but just enough that when the pressure
came on
they couldn't cognitively work at the
level they need to
and that's why they made the mistakes
they did that's coming up this week on
brian ross investigates on the long
crime
trial network brian
thanks brian when we come back a former
law enforcement officer convicted of
planting drugs
on innocent people learns his fate how
much time zachary wester will spend
behind bars
next
welcome back a former florida deputy
convicted of planting drugs
an unsuspecting motorist was sentenced
to spend more than 12 years in prison
zachary wester was accused of planting
methamphetamine and drug paraphernalia
during traffic stops and falsifying
arrest reports at the jackson county
sheriff's department
when confronted investigators found a
stash of more drugs in the back of his
patrol vehicle
a jury found wester guilty of 19 of 67
charges
12 victims took the stand during the
trial but the jury only convicted him of
three of the victims
joshua emanuel stephen van and teresa
odom
gee mr wester you've robbed me of my
credibility
being a mother and a grandmother for the
last three years
i've probably missed a year and a half
of my grandbaby's life because of this
i wish you no ill will and you'll never
know what you've done to me
until you have children of your own
the defendant's wife spoke on his behalf
asking the judge for leniency
saying he's a family man and a man of
god
i could not be prouder of this man
sitting here
he has grown into a man in the last
three years
when a portion of his life ended and he
could have ended as well
in the time after the allegations were
brought against him
he moved our family and life that we had
created here in jackson county
to my hometown in wakala after hurricane
michael wrecked our home
he was determined to make a life for
himself that suddenly didn't
involve law enforcement so we decided
that we would start our own company
the level of dedication to this business
was evident as he worked until the day
before the trial started
and even on the weekend between the two
weeks
to ensure that his customers were going
to be taken care of
the bottom of the guidelines as we often
refer to him in this case
is 84.1 months
other things to consider are the people
that are here for him
um the effect the good effect that he's
had on many in the community that he has
been in for the last several years
uh since this case has been pending
also he has a former law enforcement and
any time that you sentence them to
is probably going to be harder than most
time that you sentence other people to
since we've left here uh back on may
18th i believe was the day of the jury
verdict
uh mr wester has been locked up for at
least 23 hours a day
and has only seen the outside a couple
of times
i've looked at his community history
i've heard
the factors is set forth by the
witnesses today
and his work history in this community
his lack
of criminal history i've considered his
family ties
himself and his entire family to this
area
therefore it is the intention of the
court that you were sentenced to serve
a total of 12 years six months and eight
days
in the florida department of corrections
julie what did you think of the
statements made by wester's family
specifically his wife
do you think they helped or did the
judge already know what he's going to do
so i think most judges know before they
ever walk into the room for a sentencing
what they're going to do however they
are sometimes influenced at least by a
couple years by
a if the defendant expresses remorse or
b if the victim's family says something
that you know really
expresses how much the defendant
impacted their lives
in this case it seems that the
defendant's family the
the wife in particular really doesn't
acknowledge any wrongdoing in fact
views him as a pillar of the community
and i don't think that's something that
would be
helpful to the judge in terms of
lowering his sentence and i don't think
the judge certainly used that
in helping to lower any sentence and we
can see by the sentence
that it was closer to the top yeah the
sense of proud
she the sense of pride sorry she said
she had for him that she couldn't be
prouder
that seemed very particularly odd
considering he was being sentenced
terry when you think of the
ramifications of planting drugs on so
many people
do you think 12 years was the right
number oh i think it was the exact
right number when you think about it 67
counts and he was found guilty on 19 of
those counts
one of the counts was racketeering and
that is a first-class felony and
that you know is very serious that was
five years alone so
i think that was the right decision by
the judge all right julie terry thank
you very much and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you